the concept of Allah subhanana wa ta'ala
and regarding the concept of Allah
subhanana wa ta'ala the best reply that
any Muslim can give you the shortest and
the best and the most concise definition
of Allah subhanana wa ta'ala is given in
the glorious Quran by Allah himself in
surahlas chapter number 112 verse number
1 to4 where Allah says
say He is Allah one and only. Allah
Allah the absolute and eternal.
He begget not nor is he begotten.
There's nothing like him. This is a
fourline definition of Allah subhanana
wa ta'ala given in the glorious Quran.
Any person says so and so candidate is
God. And if that candidate fits in this
four-line definition, we Muslims have no
objection in accepting that candidate as
God. First is
say Allah one and only. Second is Allah
Allah the absolute and eternal. Third is
he begets not nor is he begotten.
And the fourth is the most stringent.
There is nothing like him. The moment
you can compare God to anything in this
world, he's not God.
This suras is the touchstone of
theology. Theo means God, logic mean
study, theology mean study of God.
Touchstone as many of you will be aware
that if you want to buy or sell jewelry,
gold jewelry, and you want to know how
pure is the gold, so you take it to a
goldsmith. He takes this touch stone and
he rubs the jewelry against the
touchstone and observes the color and
tells you that this is 24 karat gold
[clears throat] or he may tell you it is
22 karat gold or he may say it is 18
karat gold or he may say it is not gold
at all because everything that glitters
is not gold. So surahlas is the
touchstone of theology.
If any human being says that so and so
person is God or so and so candidate is
God. If it fits in this definition of
suras we Muslims have no objection in
accepting that candidate as God. Let me
give an example that there are
some human beings who consider Bhagwan
Rajnish to be God. You may have heard
the name of Bhagwan Rajnes. He was very
famous. He was from India from the
country where I come. So there are some
human beings who think he's God. So let
us put this Bhagwan Rajnes to the test
of surah class. The first is
say Allah one and only. Was Bhagan
Rajnish the only man who claimed
divinity? We have thousands of them and
many from the country where I come
India. He's not the only one. The second
test Allah Allah the absolute and
eternal was raish absolute and eternal.
When we read his autobiography we come
to know he was suffering from astama
from diabetes malitis from chronic
backachche. Imagine almighty god
suffering from aama from diabetes
malitis from chronic backachche. Third
test
he begget not nor is he begotten. We
know from his biography that Rajnes had
a mother and a father. He was born in
Jabalpur, Mhyra Pradesh. And later on in
1981 he goes to America and in a village
by the name of Oregon
he starts his own village called as
Rajnish Puram and he takes thousands of
American for a ride. Later on the
American government arrest him and puts
him behind bars. Rajnes claims that the
American government gave me slow
poisoning. Imagine almighty God being
slow poisoned. In 1985
they kick Rajnesh out of the country US
and he comes back to India and in the
state of Maharashtra in the city of
Punea he starts his new center there
Oshoku commamune and if you go there it
is mentioned on samadhi.
Samadis
when the Hindus when they when they burn
when they cremate the body nash are kept
there and on the stone it's mentioned oh
show the dashnish never born never died
but visited the earth from the 11th of
December 1931 to the 19th of January
[clears throat]
1990 never born never died but visited
the earth from the 11th of December 1931
to the 19th of January 1990. They forgot
to mention on the samadi he was not
given visas to 21 different countries of
the world. Imagine almighty god coming
in this world to visit the world and he
requires visas and the archbishop of
Greece said if you don't remove rashes
from this country we will burn his house
and the house of his disciple and the
last test
there's nothing like him is so stringent
that no one besides Allah can pass the
moment you can compare Allah to anyone
in this world he's not God.